good afternoon everybody today we have
Alex Schultz VP of growth of Facebook
and probably
old expert on growth as he can vouch
from this weekend the person I go to
when I have a really hard growth
question many people who work at
Facebook many of the founders of
Facebook in fact and very early
employees have said hiring alex has been
one of the secret successes of Facebook
that is not well understood you joined
in almost ten years ago and I think at
that point Facebook had less than a
hundred million users yeah way less than
a hundred million users Facebook now has
one point six billion and alex has been
after the importance of having a great
product maybe the second most important
driver of the heavy Naomie that's very
important people and the team anyway
thank you very much for coming to speak
to us thank you I did not pay Sam for
that introduction and I would note that
javi is my boss so hi javi but no javi
javi and Naomi Danny there are these
people who've been on the growth team
for four years and they're people like
Blake and sha Martin and and Ray and
James Wang who said that who said the
team up and and it's very nice but I am
a vp on growth I am NOT V VP of growth
um so you've had an amazing amazing
lecture series I just watched all of
them yesterday to make sure I didn't say
anything without actually having seen
what everybody else said and it was
totally awesome
I I loved what D'Angelo had to say so
that lecture if you weren't here if you
didn't watch it I strongly recommend you
go back and see what Adam D'Angelo said
because I could not I could not
emphasize his points on metrics modern
enough and so what I'm going to try and
do for the first half is go over some of
the points that have been made already
and emphasize what I think is most
important when you're thinking about
growth and what my take is and our take
is on on the Facebook growth team on
those and then in the second half try
and talk to you a little bit more about
tactics that have been particularly
particularly useful the caveat that I
think you should take on board is what
Stuart from slack and Flickr said which
is to some extent you do have a hundred
million monkeys bashing at typewriters
and I am very very lucky to be on the
growth team at Facebook to get to work
on a product like Facebook that has the
retention that Facebook does that has
everyone in the world wanting to use the
product and to say that like I drove it
or any of us drove it beyond their being
great product market fit is perhaps not
true I
can't tell you what the a/b test is if
we didn't even have a growth team at
Facebook so what matters most to growth
the single most important thing to
growth is retention Adam commented on
this in his talk and he showed you
cohorts from some real company but here
is a stylized cohort of how you should
look at retention the number of days
from acquisition is on the x axis on the
y axis is the percent of people who are
still monthly active I care a lot about
using monthly active not daily active
not weekly active there are really good
arguments for using daily actives that
people say all the time because it's
about intensity of usage but what really
really matters is that you've got skin
in the game and people come back to your
product at least once a month and then
you build on top of that engagement
revenue whatever your key metrics are
which we'll get to in a minute but
firstly I believe monthly active is the
most important thing the second thing is
how do you really calculate it so I've
got a real graph for revenue in a few
slides from Facebook from the first 250
days of our ads product which I'll show
you but a thing what's really really
important is to say that it's very easy
to calculate this curve even if you have
a thousand or a hundred users and what
you do is you look at all of your users
on the first day after they signed up
were they monthly active yes clearly
right the first 30 days everyone's going
to be monthly active I'd prefer if you
defined a month as 28 days by the way
cuz multiples of seven is really really
good for these kind of metrics because
of weeks but for the first 30 days
everyone has been active on their first
day on the second day on their third day
as a monthly active user whether they
came back or not and then what you do is
you look at day 31 and obviously only
some of your users will have been active
for 31 days everyone who signed up a day
ago was not active for 31 days so what
percentage of them were active on day 31
what percentage of them were active on
day 32 and as you go further and further
out in the number of days since
registration the number of people who
have been on your service that long
declines which means that you're metric
is going to get noisier right as you get
out to the far right-hand side of that
curve
but that doesn't mean you can't get a
handle of where things flatten out very
very early on with very small numbers of
users the number one criticism people
give me when I talk about retention as a
metric or even when you look at what
Adam presented in his presentation
earlier is you need lots and lots of
users so you need millions of users to
calculate that that is not true
we did it with thousands of users in the
early days of advertisers for Facebook
for example or you need to have had all
of those users on for a very long time
look at Adams graph it was multiple
years with months and months and months
no you can do it day by day and you can
get to a really good place super super
fast using this methodology so what are
you looking for in a retention curve
you're looking for it to flatline above
zero not flatline like a heart monitor
you want it to flat line at some line
asymptotes with the x-axis there are
three types of these curves that I've
seen the first type is where asymptotes
to the x-axis like really really close
goes down to almost zero you hear about
a lot of those companies you think about
most games right most games are Smash
Hits how many people use farmville now
versus how many people use farmville at
its absolute please tell me not fabulous
yeah okay all right how many people use
fun but I'm feeling old I had hair when
I first did one of these how many people
use farm bill now versus how many people
used to use it fun there was a smash hit
then there's other ones which look like
this where they stabilize out so you
think about minecraft right or World of
Warcraft these games that somehow have
network effects and people stay in them
for a long time the other version of
this curve I've seen is the ones where
they go down they look like they're
going to hit the x-axis and then they re
accelerate and they go up there's a few
different things that can cause that
right so you have this this overwhelming
thing that's driving you down to have
zero retention and somehow the numbers
go up again so things that drive that
for businesses and you actually I think
mentioned this in your intro one network
effects so when all your friends get on
Facebook you're much more likely to use
Facebook when all your friends get on
Twitter you're more likely used to
Twitter what
app messenger whichever social service
you're talking about there are Network
effects that really matter
network effects also count in
marketplaces when you have enough
sellers you can have enough fires when
you have enough traffic you get more
sellers and so as marketplaces go often
what you find is these old cohorts that
signed up resurrect and come back to the
service so network effects can drive the
curve up after it's flatline somewhere
or is heading towards zero the second
thing that can do this is opening up a
new interface so think about it a lot of
people would release their apps first on
iOS I actually loved Yuans talk last
week for this by the point that he made
of starting with Nokia focusing on
Android because it's what most of the
world used but in Silicon Valley we
typically build our apps first on iOS
more than more often than not and then
when someone reduce releases an Android
application and this was something I saw
with Instagram years and years ago but
when you release an Android application
people might have tried it on an iPhone
and then traded their iPhone for an
Android and no longer be able to access
your service people might have tried
your service on a friend's iPhone and
then when you add Android they come back
and use your service so that's another
thing that can can drive you up again
and then the third thing that I've seen
on these curves that drive these curves
up again is adding categories so think
about Amazon there was a really good
discussion with us two earlier or
someone earlier in this talked about
Amazon and how Amazon started with
ebooks because there was this large
inventory available of books but then
they added in another category and then
they added in another category over time
and imagine there'll be people who came
to Amazon to buy that one book but then
two years down the line Amazon suddenly
had kitchenware I don't know or fashion
and they came back and then they bought
fashion and it brought the more use
cases to come back more monthly active
this was true with eBay we added motors
I remember being at eBay like and we had
to do all of our reporting on gross
merchandise volume with and without
motors and no one had ever believed that
you could buy a car online and eBay did
it and it created a whole new use case
for people many of whom were existing
eBay customers who now had one more
category they could shop in so you want
to cut curve the asymptotes to a line
parallel to the
x-axis you can do it with far more
limited amounts of data than most people
think you can by using the technique I
outlined earlier and I'll show you a
real world example in a few slides and
there are three types of curves that
I've seen curve the asymptotes like this
awesome your company will survive now
how big will it get we have another
question curves that go straight to zero
that's okay
you could be in games and your job is to
produce one here after another after
another ea doesn't expect whatever FIFA
2012 to still have lots of users now if
they've released FIFA 27 so it's okay
there are businesses we're hitting the x
axis is okay but you need to know you're
in one of those businesses and then the
third that I've seen is the curve going
up and that can be driven by network
effects that can be driven by being
available on more platforms that can be
driven by adding categories to your
marketplace or service from this falls
out a brilliant way to look at growth
and this guy Danny Ferrante who was at
Yahoo who's one of the first members of
the growth team runs core data science
what Facebook is totally awesome he's
really the brains behind the operation
and the mouth Danny came up or brought
this to Facebook and it's a simple way
to look at growth we were looking at
growth as how many users will be growing
by week on week we looked at it at an
absolute basis and looking at like that
we were like huh okay so we're signing
up whatever it was a million a week and
we're growing by whatever it was eight
hundred thousand a week I don't know I'm
cool we're turning 200 thousand people
and we never actually looked at it in
this way when we change the way we look
at things to say well ok the net growth
is eight hundred thousand a week the new
users are 1 million a week but what is
churn and resurrection and what we
actually found at the time and I can't
remember the absolute numbers so I'll
just make some up but imagine you're
churning 1.3 million so not 200,000 1.3
million you're resurrecting 1.1 million
so plus 1 minus 1 point 3 plus 1 point 1
you've got net 800,000 in growth but
that 800,000 in growth is being driven I
think I did the math wrong 800,000
growth is being driven by a different
order of magnitude from
churn and resurrection than you realized
and for that helps you focus on how do I
stop people churning how do I get people
to come back to my service who are
coming who are not coming back to my
service right now so once you have your
attention curves and once you start to
have a business with retention you need
to look at your growth accounting not
just how many users are we acquiring
makes sense
overall the number one thing I focus on
for growth number one thing we focus on
for growth is retention so what gets you
retained in any given service magic
moment what is the moment when you used
Airbnb what is the moment when you used
door - when you use slack when you used
Facebook Linkedin whatsapp whatever the
product what is that moment when you
went yes I've got it right on Facebook
it's friends you see that first friend
that person who I'm got completely the
wrong crowd for this what the person
from high school who you lost contact
with as you grow over and moved away but
you see that person and you go wow I
haven't talked to them in years let's
see what's going on with their life and
they've had a kid and lost their hair -
and you feel better about yourself that
is a magic moment on Facebook so how
quickly can you drive the user to that
magic moment you look at Airbnb right
they've talked about like the delight
that they give people they've talked
about these different screenshots of the
stages in the user journey that they've
they created as a map of the user
journey getting that first person
reserved your house staying at that
first property those are magic moments
eBay buying your first item from a
stranger online nowadays that doesn't
seem crazy but back when I was working
at eBay in the UK that was revolutionary
and people really their eyes lit up when
you talked to them about it in Germany
they had this great a device by Ernst
mines that showed the build up of when
you were waiting for the auction to
finish and for you to make your first
purchase and that was such an adrenaline
endorphin moment you know that users
loved it nowadays it's it seems a long
time ago but those magic moments are
what you need to look for so how do you
find them where you can find them in the
non scalable way which is daunting or
just sound
the Tivoli obvious you can actually
think through what is the experience on
my product what do I want people to do
you can ask your first users okay you're
keeping using my product why are you
keeping using my what is the thing that
makes you happy to use my product what
was that first moment it's non scalable
but it generally works when you ask
people what is the best thing about
Facebook the first thing they say is
connecting with friends and family in
all the research why do you like
Facebook all it helps me connect with my
friends and family so you can do it the
non scalable way or you can do the
scalable way look for correlations so
mark has talked at startup school
himself and he said that we focused on
getting people to 10 friends in 14 days
it's a smooth curve right number of
friends on the x-axis and percent
retained on the y-axis it's not like
there's a step change at 10 if you get 9
you don't retain if you get 11 you do
and it all changes at 10 now it's
clearly a smooth curve and we picked a
point on the curve but there's a strong
correlation between number of friends
you've got in the first 14 days and
whether you retain honor there's a
correlation between number of friends in
the first day but there are correlations
for any product like did you place a bid
did you do a buy it now or did you list
an item on ebay was the thing that was
completely correlated with retention for
eBay you can imagine I don't know I mean
doordash was found at Stanford right
like you could imagine Ford or - you
placed your first order and that order
arrives to your door and whether you've
placed an order or not and how many
orders you place in the first week
probably they are is that they are
actually correlated with whether you
retain or not so you need to look for
the magic moment of your product by
talking to users and then try and
validate that with correlations so make
sense cool I love this I put it in every
presentation hit - um so I'm lucky
enough to have been trained in physics
at Cambridge in the UK and my favorite
my favorite lecture series
not my favorite lecture but my favorite
lectures was in a thing called
dimensional reasoning and so it's easy
for me to stand up here and say okay so
you need to get flattered attention and
then you have a viable business that's
not actually true that's kind of a glib
statement if you're producing a
your network and you have 5% retention
you're not going to long-term have a
tremendous social network or a messaging
app like what use would watts that be if
only 5% of your friends actually used
whatsapp you signed up for it I may be
useless right and there's no way we
could release 1 billion plus numbers of
active user this that's true for us on
the other hand if you have a marketplace
that is selling fashion and you have 5
or 10 percent retention but those people
spend a lot of money you have a totally
viable business and so the level of
retention you need varies dramatically
by the category that you're in obviously
the higher the better is true in
everything like if you can have an eBay
type business model or Amazon type
business model with 90 percent retention
you probably end up bigger than Amazon I
mean that would be incredible but I
think the point I like to make is you
can figure it out and I love this as an
inspirational story so Jeffery Taylor
was this British physicist he was on the
edge of the Manhattan Project he wasn't
in the core he ended up winning a Nobel
Prize later for a different area and the
US and Russian government's were
releasing these images to say this is
how big our bomb is but they weren't
releasing the actual power because that
was a closely guarded state secret
and so what Jeffery Taylor did to use
this technique or dimensional reasoning
where you look at the units in the
metric you are trying to achieve so
joules right for energy is joules
kilograms times meters squared over
seconds squared that's what joules
decomposes into in this case kilograms
what you're going to use the volume of
the air times the density of the air
which handily is one so you've now got
meters cube times meters squared over
second squared so meters to the five of
a second times seconds to minus two the
time is on here the diameter the radius
of the sphere is on here you just plug
the radius in as M you plug the diameter
at the time in as seconds and you end up
getting 25 kilotons as the output you
get 10 to the 14 I think is what it
works out as and it turns out the bomb
was 21 kilotons as measured by the US
government
it could take one photo and figure out
the most closely guarded state secret in
the United States at the time you can
figure out what retention you need to
have if he
figure that out so here go I promise
this is an actual curve I presented a
few different events I've taken up the
numbers because I'm worried they're
state secrets but this is from 2007 to
2008 I joined the week we started our
ads business at Facebook our
self-service our business by us the the
pink speaks to the right hand axis the
blue speaks to the left hand axis what
the blue is is how many advertisers had
been in the system at least one day two
days three days because the x-axis is
number of days from acquisition makes
sense so the thing has only been around
250 days so zero people have been
advertisers 251 days ago and we're on
there 250 first date and all the people
have been active at least on day zero
and then each of those pink data points
is the total revenue we achieved from
every user who had registered who was
using the service on their 30th day or
their 31st day divided by how many users
signed up 30 or 31 days ago not how many
were active right how many signed up so
total in the cohort who signed up 30 or
31 days ago divided by you divide the
revenue they made in a day by that
number of users and that gives you that
shape of curve that's up there I
stumbled over my words a bit there I
promise you if you look over it again it
makes perfect sense
I did this with Danny back in 2008 the
really important things I want you to
take away from looking at this curve is
look how flat the pink line is like I've
been talking about curves flattening out
this is an actual curve flattening out
and look how quickly it's flattened out
by 100 days you can pretty much predict
what the line is going to beat at 200
days I've seen this over and over I've
seen this with engagement so if you
divide time spent by the same
denominator I've seen it actually for
sentiment if you have a large enough
Sentiment Survey and you divide it by
that same denominator I have seen it for
posts I have seen it for photos uploaded
messages sent like you can use the same
techniques that I talked about for
determining how much retention you have
and whether your business
is viable to figure out what is the
lifetime value of one of your customers
if I was to acquire the total
addressable market for my business today
what revenue will I be making in a
hundred days that's what this curve
allows you to do you can predict it for
posts you can predict it for pageviews
time spent whatever you want the same
methodology works for engagement that
works for retention and actually
retention is often the biggest driver of
this metric and we did this with very
little data later on there's a stat we
are ok releasing which was end of 2012
we had about 700 thousand active
advertisers beginning we had about 300
thousand active advertisers um and this
was 5 years before that so you can
imagine there was a very small data set
that was behind calculating this the
last thing is I said things get noisy
the further out you go you can literally
see that on this graph right the
variance and the numbers the further to
the right you go on the graph so now how
do you operate for growth most important
thing is have a clear goal Brian who is
awesome on growth marketing Facebook
great guy he always says if you are a
growth team your product is a number one
of the most brilliant things I think
that mark did in the early days of
Facebook was he aligned the entire
company on monthly active people as a
goal now why does this matter it matters
for a bunch of reasons but the biggest
and most important reason is I think it
aligns everyone when you have a company
of more than 2 or 3 people or by the way
a team of more than 2 or 3 people
certainly when it gets to the hundreds
you can't control what anyone does I
mean you could probably control what one
person does but then the other 199 would
do whatever the hell they wanted so what
do you want to do you want to make sure
everyone is pointing in the same
direction and that direction is
generally right so let's think back to
the early days of any company whether
it's Facebook whether it's Airbnb
LinkedIn whatever you want to look at it
would be completely reasonable to have a
goal of revenue right you want your
company to stay alive you want
to make enough money that your company
can still be viable that you can employ
people that evaluation goes up so a
reasonable person could say I think we
need to drive towards revenue at the
same time you could have a metric that
was like if you're at the MB number of
hosts if your Facebook number of posts
if your door - number of orders I don't
even know what these companies metrics
are beyond Facebook's you could easily
have a production metric or a
consumption metric you could have a time
spent in our service metric and every
one of those metrics would be a
completely reasonable metric to drive
for so you've got ten reasonable people
maybe five of them think you should have
monthly active people one is really
focused on revenue two are looking at
time spent and two are looking at number
of posts everyone is pushing in a
reasonable direction that is vaguely
aligned but probably will have conflict
if you want to get an ad in front of a
user as quickly as you possibly can you
may not necessarily want to put friends
in front of them immediately if you want
to get them to post you may dial up the
composer and push down the ads I don't
know like these are trade offs that you
could be making and if the whole team
isn't clear what the goal is they will
be in conflict so having a clear goal
that your company looks to drive is
really really important and having that
goal the m80 in my opinion is the best
metric that you can drive for because it
is that once a month visitation that
base level you can drive off of if
you're going to do a consumer internet
company but fundamentally the most
important thing is pick a goal your
team's product is a goal focus on that
goal align the company around that goal
and then you're going to operate
correctly for growth the other thing I
always say is you don't need a growth
team if you are like a small company if
you're even series-a don't have a growth
team don't hire someone like me the
whole company's job should be growth and
very happy at Facebook so I don't want
to Joel offer but the whole company's
the whole company's goal should be
growing the purpose of a startup is to
grow so what is the number you want to
grow and align the whole company against
growing that number does that make sense
now Naomi is amazing and now I mean
someone people don't know that well out
of Facebook but she runs product and
engineering for growth she's brilliant
she's been at Facebook 12 years so when
you know who say I'm original I feel not
original every day she sits like 3 feet
from me she's amazing anyway she has
this approach that we use to iterate
through our growth planning cycles which
I think works really well understand
first of all understand what is going on
look at all the data you have talk to
your users ask your users what they
think understand everything that is
going on with your product you can
possibly understand what matters
retention are you churning too many do
you have the retention is the revenue
going up on a per user basis what are
the acquisition channels you're getting
which channel are people resurrecting
through are they resurrecting through
email is it push notifications what's
going on understand what's going on to
your system have that all tracked then
identify look through all of those
different metrics all of that different
research you get in and understand and
identify where are their opportunities
where do you see big drop-offs do you
have a lot of people with push
notifications turned on who are not
receiving push notifications do you have
a lot of people who are receiving push
notifications who are not clicking on
them do you have loads and loads of
social media traffic but no search
traffic are your email viral invites
working but your SMS ones not and what
is the difference between those let go
and look at the data and identify where
there are gaps and then try and double
down on fixing those gaps in the
execution phase now to this day this is
still how we run growth of Facebook and
you can even see a talk now I mean I
gave online 9 years ago I think @fa
eight or nine years ago where we talked
about using this approach and we have
kept it going understand what's going on
identify the opportunities in that data
you've understood and then execute
against it
another really interesting thing I think
was said earlier is no data debt sucks
and you're going to regret it later and
your intuition is going to run out at
some point and then you're going to want
data in 2009 we actually shut down all
of the work the growth team was doing
during January and we only spell
the time logging and making sure every
critical flow on Facebook registration
at the time we didn't know we didn't log
clicks on emails so clicks on emails I
mean seems obvious now but we didn't
have it clicks on emails did you come
did you then actually log in or did you
fail in the password entry all of these
different things we logged them so that
we could understand what was going on
and that was super critical because
actually in March that year we had a
massive growth slowdown and we were not
able to hunt we would not have been able
to understand what was going on if we
hadn't under logging in January because
what went on was actually super nuanced
and without that logging in place we
wouldn't have known get the data logged
so you can run through this process
so speaking of data I am very very lucky
at Facebook I do growth marketing
I run the AUSA mental
internationalization team but I also run
the analytics team for the company and
that's been a couple of years now when I
talk about data to people internally I
like to say these three points there's a
meme in the valley that you operate
either for user experience or for
metrics and I really want to bust that
mean data when used in the right way
gives you empathy about your users one
example I've talked about in the past is
we launched a product on Facebook that
you may have seen on on your big 42 inch
monitors no one has a big 42 inch
monitor in here but I'm sure some of you
do at home that has on the right-hand
side all the friends you could chat with
on Facebook but at the top it has this
list of stories that's ticking over
called ticker when you're on a small
screen that product used to collapse
into the right-hand column of Facebook
and push things down so that you could
still see these stories ticking over
that product worked great for all of us
who had huge numbers of friends who are
creating a lot of content on big screens
but if you went to the Philippines where
there was huge usage in internet cafes
and people were on narrow screens the
majority of them ended up having that in
the right-hand column and the majority
of them were low engagement with
Facebook and couldn't see people you may
know below the
and so we actually lost friending
amongst users who are very different to
ourselves and we only figured out what
was happening by looking at the data and
saying huh why is this bad on small
screens and awesome on big screens why
is it not so great for low engagement
users and super for power users it was
because we use the data to understand
these users who are different to us here
in Silicon Valley now think about it I
presume I don't know I'm seeing a lot of
Apple products here I have a lenovo at
the moment but most of you probably have
iPhones who as I phone yeah who have an
Android you're the best
most people in the world are using
androids that everyone's room has an
iPhone first and foremost you don't
understand I'm actually forgetting how
to use iOS now which is actually a
problem in my job but like I've got an
Android because the maybe not majority a
vast number of our users use Android as
yam fed yet in the last talk and I need
to understand what the Android operating
system offers but I can't understand
Android and iOS well as a user at the
same time so I used data to understand
what's going on in iOS you need to gain
empathy for your users and research is
great and talking to your customers is
great but if you listen to the the
twitch guy Emmet you know talk to your
users then go away and build the product
to serve them and look at the data in my
opinion would be the next thing to
validate if you build the right thing if
you're doing the right thing if your
research actually ties up with what your
users have said to you so data gives you
empathy data it's not a trade-off
between metrics and users if you build
the right metrics you are optimizing for
the users - data predicts the future
over and over and over again I love this
quote it's science fiction author I
think but like the future is here it's
just not evenly distributed yet so those
curves that show you the retention when
I said you can look at your total
addressable market and say if I signed
them all up how much revenue would I get
or you just look at who you signed up
today let's say back in those days we
signed up a thousand
appetizers in a day I could tell you how
much revenue they would contribute
hundred days out because of that curve
now also your users are going to ramp up
so a user who shops in one category if
your ebay or if your Amazon and then
buys in a second category in a third
category is clearly going to get more
valuable right shopping the shop driving
up same store sales is a common
technique in e-commerce okay so how many
of you users are increasing the number
of categories they're shopping in you
see someone sign up
what likelihood is it that they're going
to add extra categories and what is your
revenue going to be in the future
you can predict that with data a B tests
are another great thing see all these
people walking in the science March
believing in in science and then when
you apply the scientific method to their
product and run an a/b test they ship
the thing that looked bad in the a/b
test because they didn't believe the a/b
test I see that with all kinds of
startups I talked to a B test tell you
what's going to happen when you ship
them to 100% use them it works
finally and this is something mark
actually added recently for me data
helps you make decisions faster if you
can not as the CEO have to have a
conversation over something where you
could just run a test your company is
going to be able to move quicker because
every decision won't have to come to you
people in the team if they're clear on
what that goal is that northstar metric
is they can run the test see if they
move the metric and then only come to
you when they know if they've moved the
metric or not decisions like that help
you move faster knowing what your most
important priority is because you've
looked at the data that helps you move
faster make sense cool so now you want
to me to push forth as much of the time
as possible so I'm pushing for as much
of the time as possible
so let's talk about tactics first
hundred users Sam talks about this
brilliantly if you actually listen I
thought Tracy in the previous
conversations was just fantastic when
she talked about getting thirty of her
friends in the construction industry to
try plan grid and then asking twenty
thousand him to pay and twenty nine of
them kept
like ask your friends first for your
first hundred customers get people who
will give you honest feedback and I love
the point about make them pay if it's a
paid product second research and then
reach out to who you'd like to have as
your users totally makes sense right
like you can do what like how Oscar was
discovered by the LOB team right just
email a bunch of people don't get caught
in a spam filter don't just Auto
generate emails or you'll definitely get
caught in a spam filter but send
personal emails get introductions see
which friend you have in common I
emphasize by the way I have never
started a start-up so I might be
entirely the wrong person to tell you
about first hundred users but Sam asked
me to UM third social media and PR PR is
non scalable but it can give you amazing
bumps amazing bumps and in the early
days I think PR is a good growth lever
later on I think companies don't realize
when PR is stop being a growth lever
because they have these other metrics
but you can get these great one-time
bumps just know you can't get them every
single week and sometimes they are
one-off and finally buy ads I am NOT as
against ads as families as a great
method for growing users I think that
buying ads can be absolutely fantastic I
built my career buying ads two of the
most valuable Internet companies Google
and Facebook they call their revenue
from selling ads like ads are actually a
good thing if you get the targeting
right we're going to talk about that in
a second if you are having a growth team
if you're focused on growth tactics what
people talk about is growth hacking
although I hate the term if you pour
fuel this is a picture from a guy called
Nick on my team Nick caesarian I did not
tell him to hold his hand into the
flames which we'll see in a second if
you pour lighter fluid onto dead coals
with no spark you get nothing and if
there's one thing to take away from this
lecture
you need to have product market fit to
drive growth you need retention to drive
growth otherwise every growth tactic
every acquisition draft tactic you could
possibly run doesn't matter but if you
have an Esparta if you have a glowing
ember you can pour fuel on the fire of
your product and that is what growth
tactics does so I look at things based
on
channel targeting creative and then
conversion so if you think about channel
I'm going to try and do some Greatest
Hits here if you look at SEO you think I
have to think about keyword research
which keywords do I want to show up for
on Google on the other search engines
and make sure you have content targeted
against those keywords you need to get
links links from the Internet to your
site if you're a Silicon Valley startup
you typically get a lot of links of
high-value sites so you usually don't
have to worry about that but then you
need to link inside your site many
people will tell you links don't matter
anymore in my experience that is not
true
I don't know why it's not true but it's
not been true in my experience and then
finally there are a bunch of basics out
there on SEO you can read them up there
are load of websites that talk about
them SEO book malls they're a bunch of
websites out there you can read about
SEO tactics for paid search the biggest
thing I see people do wrong is they
don't think about incrementality they
buy paid search and they don't
necessarily say well would I have got
those customers anyway so look really
hard if you're going to buy paid search
as a start up you should see a step
change in your line your marketing team
if you've reached the stage where you
have a marketing guy should show you a
line that is flat and then they turn on
paid search and it goes up that's the
same of any ads if you are a small
start-up if you're a big company
increment ality analysis there's this
great berkeley professor steve to dallas
we've done a deep study in it with ebay
that i love and i I think he's really
smart big companies you have to be
really really smart about getting in
karate you're a small startup showing me
a step change do you think about
marginal not absolute ROI so people
always look at like I spent this much I
got this much how valuable is it that's
not what you want to look at you want to
look at the last dollar you spent how
much did you get for that
not overall does that make sense not as
many nods I'm going to blast through
that look at look at marginal ROI look
at diminishing return curves in
economics and then again you need to do
your keyword research so email SMS and
push notifications this is something
every startup gets wrong we always
optimize for ourselves have you seen the
Instagram thing on the internet where
someone shows a phone of like an
Instagram user with a million followers
when they posted something and they have
push notifications on and the string
just goes and all the notifications are
coming in at high speed like that's what
will
for our own products for our products
we're the power users and by Nature
every startup I have gone and talked to
has always optimized for themselves has
always optimized for the power user and
so by optimizing for the power user what
do you do well we shouldn't put that on
by default because it's going to
completely spam my home screen power
users are smart if you give them the
options they know how to turn off
notifications
it's your marginal user you should care
about with notifications that person for
whom they receive their first like on
Instagram or the host that gets their
first notification on Airbnb or the
seller that gets their first bid on eBay
or the buyer who's just been outbid in
their first item that's the person that
needs to get the notification and needs
to respond to it and you need to
optimize for in your head
marginal user is the number one thing in
email SMS push notifications and even
offline mail which love was talking
about and is still very important for
many companies people get wrong they
optimize for themselves beyond that you
need to make sure it gets delivered
opened clicked on etc there's so much
more here and if I push through all of
it I'm not going to get to any questions
do you want me to get to questions this
is pretty important however no much
there's nobody there that everybody
makes me so think about on-site
merchandising you own a lot of media
there's this idea of earned bought and
owned media does that make sense
so if you post on Facebook and it gets
loads of likes you've earned that media
right if you bought an ad on Facebook or
Google or somewhere you've bought that
media and then if they're on your own
website you own that media people
underestimate the value of owned media
if you have a lot of traffic on your
site ask them to invite their friends
ask them to complete that next action in
your product think about your on-site
merchandising as an extension of your
product but understand the on-site
merchandising is a marketing problem so
how can you trigger the right thing
someone has just bought an item for you
immediately like Amazon does trigger for
them a
of suggestions of like why don't you buy
this this and this or customers who
bought this also bought this works
incredibly well what about creative
creative is really important it should
be personalized because there on your
site you know their name hey Alex why
don't you buy these items that other
similar customers have bought performs
well way better than by these other
items that similar customers have bought
that's one simple personalization but
instead of just saying this customer
bought this item you should do a
prediction this person all the items
they've ever bought let me predict for
them in a personalized way what item
they should buy look at Facebook and how
often we say five of your friends have
done X social context that's
personalization use people's own profile
picture we have a great personalization
example where when you are on a Facebook
page we show you what your ad would look
like if you bought it with a buy this
button underneath it it could not be
more personalized on-site merchandising
gives you so many opportunities to
deeply deeply personalize the creative
and finally paid an organic social I do
work for Facebook we do make all of our
money from ads and I personally think
that I am not the best person to speak
about buying ads on Facebook because I'm
the guy who buys ads off Facebook to
drive traffic to Facebook but what I'll
say is if I left Facebook today and I
was a startup I would be crazy not to
use our custom audiences and look-alike
targeting so I highly highly encourage
you if you think about nothing else on
Facebook ads to look into those it's a
great way if you say these are my best
customers upload the list of Facebook
how do I find more customers like those
it works incredibly well for a lot of
companies the other thing across all
social media is to a great extent you're
dealing with interesting squared because
the click-through rate on your thing the
light gray or whatever in your thing
will be related to how interesting it is
and also the distribution whether it's
being shared via messaging apps re
shared on Twitter or on Facebook will be
driven by whether people found it
interesting make sense cool okay
targeting behavioral is most important
so what you did is much more important
than who you are there are 50 year old
sick
dear old parents and grandparents who
need to friends to be active on Facebook
and there are some who need 500 and
there are teenagers who need 500 friends
and some who need to and you're much
better to figure out like what is the
behavior that tells you that then say on
a demographic basis I'm going to do this
versus this you know people who buying
Nikes men's Nike trainers typically are
men but sometimes people buy for their
boyfriend or their husband or their dad
or whatever and so if you just target
women with women's trainers and men with
men's trainers you are making a mistake
what you should do is look at what
signals you to show the right ad or the
right content to the right person the
right time
targeting matters I've talked about this
before okay creative creative is
important but it's nowhere near as
important as the above - unless you have
a 10x creative if you produce the Dollar
Shave Club video probably it's very very
worth it but most people don't produce a
piece of creative of that amazing that
changes the world typically I find
targeting comes before creative in every
single way and channel comes before that
does that make sense so creative it is
awesome and really important and can
give you a big uplift but think about
your channel first and you're targeting
second if you have created those you
should put it in context you should
personalize it you should give it a call
to action on call to action this is a
great example where on every ad back in
the day on Facebook we had a little link
at the top that said advertise we
translated it wrong by mistake in French
we found this with the data and in
French we translated it to Claire and AD
create an ad and we had significantly
more actually 40% more acquisition from
that channel that was at the time a
single most important channel for
advertiser acquisition we took the
French translation and we reverse
translator and change the whole world
instead of saying the kind of passive
advertise to the active create an ad and
we achieved a 40% bump in that most
important channel for us for advertiser
acquisition that is the call to action
like what you say matters so when I say
creative doesn't matter as much as
channel and targeting it still matters a
lot and the words you use matter a lot
this is the example I said about in
context with intent if you are on your
own page this used to be the ad we would
show to you that say hey this is what
your ad would look like elsewhere on the
site and you can see that by our this
was the hour that we doubled advertiser
acquisition for Facebook with the push
of the weekly push if you want to see
more about this Brian hell does a great
talk about this their fate and it's
online and then the last thing yes
the last thing is conversion conversion
is really really important but it's not
important until you thought about all
the other things first so things to
think about with conversion the landing
page people land on will determine what
your conversion rate is going to be if
you can don't have one button on it that
they then have to click to go to the
registration form put the registration
form in the landing page it's important
to know what your most important metric
is though back at eBay what we had was
this original metric confirmed
registered users and a new metric
activated confirmed registered users and
an activated confirmed registered user
was someone who bought an item bid on an
item listed an item and a confirmed
registered user with someone who
registered and confirmed and that was it
to get confirmed registered users we
wanted to pump all of our search traffic
this was back in 2004 we were spending
huge amounts on search we wanted to pump
all of our search traffic at the
registration page to get activated
confirmed registered users we actually
wanted to land it on the search term
that you were looking for so if you were
looking for a trampoline show you the
trampolines you could buy on it eBay
that change and we change all of our
advertising to change the landing page
drops confirmed registered users
significantly that we were acquiring for
eBay but it increased activated
confirmed registered users it increased
revenue and lifetime value per
registered user and it increased total
revenue per day from the people we were
acquiring so although I think you can
focus on the registration form really
hard in e-commerce sometimes it's really
really important to land people on what
they're searching for so that they will
activate and they will buy on your
service so it's not as simple as just
put the registration form online
but we did do that at Facebook so the
final thing I'd like to say is Facebook
moves fast and move fast is an absolute
core value for us as a company like core
core core value and we still do bold
things like taking messenger out of
Facebook that was challenging at the
time but I think now people have seen
how valuable a decision that was and I
was a project that I was deeply involved
and RAM um we're willing to move fast
we're willing to be bold because
fundamentally a good plan violently
executed on today is better than a
perfect plan next week data helps you
move fast
these growth tactics help you move fast
there's oz talks about making decisions
with seventy percent of the data not 90
percent of the data and I deeply believe
in that so move fast focus on retention
and have one key metrics that you care
about for your company's growth thank
you okay apparently we have time for one
question I'm sorry go for it hello so
when we came behind see about creating
so the question was for the magic
moments you can kind of tell how you can
figure out when they happen but how can
you create them I mean honestly if you
look at LinkedIn Facebook Twitter every
social network in the known universe
what we do is we immediately ask you to
import your contacts so once we know
that friends is the thing that we need
to do for you we focus on what is the
way to remove friction from getting new
friends if you look at the example I
used with eBay we hadn't really figured
out that activating you was important to
generating the revenue long term so we
shifted the landing page from the
registration form to the search results
so we got you to the item you wanted to
buy as quickly as possible and that
caused you to activate and get to that
magic moment faster so you know those
the kind of things once you identify it
I actually think the tactics fall out
very logically my boss javi likes to say
that common sense is the least common of
all senses and I agree with him but if
you step back and you just look at okay
if I want more people to buy an item on
eBay should I land them on the
registration page or the search results
page you probably land them on the
search results page and that would get
them to that magic moment faster
hey thank you okay
[Applause]